pam pam pam pam pam at on bien j'ai
perdu là notre direct ah [ __ ] la
dernière série qui m'a mis une claque
ses e-mails disent trahis ou de mikaela
show elle
ça m'a mis une vraie vraie vraie vraie
claque c'est une des séries les plus
brillantes de 2020 et ça parle badin
d'un fait qui lui est arrivé où elle
s'est fait carrément violée puis même ça
parle surtout du consentement mais sous
toutes ses formes c'est brillantissime
[Musique]
chandler de friends bref moi j'ai une
série qui me touche beaucoup
cn men and monsters j'attends la saison
3 enfin même la saison 4 on la saison 4
comme un fou mais à priori le tournage a
été reculé à cause du coc vide mais il
ya des phases hallucinante dedans très
poignante et qui m'ont tiré des petite
larmichette voilà deux il ya une qui est
ancienne mais qui est pour moi
fondatrice de tout ce qui m'a moins
inspiré arrested development qui est des
plus grandes séries comédie de tous les
temps avec jason bateman michael cera
c'est la série la plus folle en terme de
narration j'aurais adoré participer à
l'écriture de sa et une dernièrement que
j'ai vu qu'ils s'appellent dave qui une
série fx et que qui est totalement dans
vos mood aussi dans un autre type de
comédie mais que j'aurais adoré écrire
aussi ouais ouais mais c'est pareil à
cause du cowitz a foutu un gros bordel
mais c'est la saison 3 de succession
enfin la saison deux mamies par terre
autant la saison une chute et un peu
dubitatif au début diop sadek y avait du
mal à accrocher avec les persos la
saison 2 et j'attends la saison 3 avec
impatience mais je pense que je vais
attendre longtemps
cette question est censée être celle de
dice et développement
écoutez là si vous avez une telle est
allé voir et après vous dira oui enfin
je vois ce qu'il faut faire
[Musique]
game of thrones j'aurais adoré jouer un
gars avec une épée avec des dragons
il ya plein de trucs que je devais moi
j'en joue envie de jouer un flic et j'ai
peut-être joué un stade et je suis trop
content et ouais un truc un peu kpp un
peu peau de bête un peu tout ça un peu
game of thrones way
[Musique]
bah validé validé j'étais à fond pendant
le confinement et je me suis toute en
filets d'un coup tous les tous les
épisodes et c'était très addictif c'est
super bien faire valider sinon dave que
j'ai maté aussi pendant le confinement
après je mate tellement de trucs moi je
crois que je mettais une série pas repas
par jour beaucoup n'ont au contraire
moi je trouve c'est important d'avoir
aussi ses séries à soir ça fait partie
de la liberté du couple et de
l'autonomie du petit jardin secret qu'il
faut au contraire cultiver la plante
série que je regarde sans elle et
qu'elle regarde sur moi aussi important
[Musique]
comment elle s'appelle est sûre et du
bio c'est love kraft l'offre coiffe
country que j'aime beaucoup et
franchement j'attends tous les lundis de
voir un épisode
j'adore j'adore le sujet j'adore comment
ils le traitent j'adore comment il parle
des noirs dans cette amérique
dégueulasse des années 50 60
tous se font un peu magie société
secrète est assez incroyable
elle m'a bien katché cette série ça
restera quand même toujours le sixième
sens même si c'est pas une série bâtard
qui m'a dit il est mort je fais c'est
comme si tu prenais tout le film tu le
jeter à la poubelle dès la première
seconde
[Musique]
arrested development
je lui montrerai aussi à hawaï met your
mother
parce que c'est génial je montrais plein
de sitcoms américaines comme ça que moi
je suis fan
est ce que c'est important moi je trouve
les séries aux mondiaux fils je
montrerai tous ces petits basique
d'humour pour qu'elles soient armés pour
la vie